[Music]
there is no better time to make painting
than when everybody thinks it's dead
you're free of market concerns you're
free of all that stuff it's not so hot
that everyone is demanding that the work
be one kind of thing or another and you
can work away at what you're doing and
working evolve and you can get somewhere
uh when we've had major times of
financial distress in this country like
the 30s and the Great Depression a lot
of people argue that that some of the
best work was made I actually don't
think it was America's greatest hour art
I think the best period for me in
American art was the 50s and maybe 50s
and early 60s late 40s early 50s 60s and
that could be seen as a time when
America opened its arms to largely
Jewish but other immigrants fleeing
Hitler and we became a kind of beacon
you know as a free and open society and
we attracted some of the best and
brightest from all over the world and
that together with our own homegrown
artists who probably felt very buoyed by
America's newfound role and
in the world and Paris and other art
centers were now you know either in
shambles or didn't seem like a great
place to be nurtured as an artist I
think that probably has more to do with
with why it was a particularly a great
period to make to make art in America
I suppose
said that crisis is a sieve it sort of
shakes out what's going on and we'll you
know separate the wheat from the shaft
it will it will play a deciding role and
who keeps working and who falls by the
wayside
[Music]